[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat vous le savez
la promesse est dans le titre donné du
sens à l'actualité vous proposez des
clés de compréhension des crises que
nous traversons justement on va parler
de la contre offensive annoncée de
l'armée ukrainienne pour ouvrir cette
émission quand peut-elle être déclenché
quelle région sera visée dans quel état
sont les forces russes nos experts
militaires et géopolitiques répondront
dans une minute et puis pour notre
second débat c'est le contenu et
l'avenir de la loi immigration que je
vous propose d'analyser j'ai résumé les
choses dans le journal Le Monde en
disant que nous devions être désormais
gentil avec les gentils c'est avec les
étrangers qui veulent travailler en
France respecter nos règles parler notre
langue être amoureux de notre drapeau et
être méchant avec les méchant c'est à
dire que nous devons ne pas accepter que
quelqu'un qui ne veut pas s'intégrer qui
ne respecte pas nos règles qui commet
des actes de vacances ne doit pas rester
sur le sol national derrière la formule
simpliste quels sont les points
saillants de cette réforme faut-il
forcément un nouveau texte alors qu'on a
voté 20 lois immigration en 30 ans la
loi dans l'examen parlementaire et
reporté sera-t-elle ou non ceux-ci sonné
en confrontera les arguments de nos
invités politiques dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord le front ukrainien
dans l'attente d'une contre-offensive
c'est un sujet signé Jérôme Rabier avec
la fin de l'hiver et de la boue qui
accompagne le des gels empêchant toute
avancer significative l'Ukraine prépare
sa contre-offensive pour tenter de
reprendre une partie des territoires
conquis par la Russie pour se faire les
Ukrainiens peuvent compter sur l'arrivée
des premiers chars lourds réclamaient de
longue date par le président zellenski
les États-Unis le Royaume-Uni et surtout
l'Allemagne ont confirmé l'arrivée sur
zone de leur premier char promis en
janvier oui nous avons livré des chars
léopards comme nous l'avions annoncé
d'autres exemplaires notamment venus
d'Espagne doivent venir prochainement
appuyer les forces ukrainiennes dans
leurs opérations un atout décisif qui
vient s'ajouter aux nombreux matériels
reçus comme ces pièces d'artillerie de
fabrication française mais côté russes
aussi l'hiver a permis de reconstituer
des forces selon Vladimir Poutine
les partisans de la guerre prévoit
d'envoyer plus de 400 420 440 chars
d'assaut en Ukraine il en va de même
pour les munitions pendant cette période
nous en produirons de nouveau et nous
moderniserons ce qui existe déjà plus de
les deux camps publient des vidéos
d'usine d'armement qui tournent à plein
régime avec un objectif
persuadé ces forces comme sa population
que la victoire viendra mais pour leur
personne ne sait où pourrait se dérouler
les prochains affrontements décisifs
l'hiver a permis à chacun de consolider
ses positions ce qui rendra plus
difficile et je vous présente mes
invités tout de suite Christine du going
Clément bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
chercheuse en géopolitique pour la chair
à risque de l'IAE Paris Impe Panthéon
Sorbonne le général Dominique trinquant
bonsoir bienvenue à vous ancien chef de
la mission militaire française auprès de
l'ONU Patricia lemonnieres bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes grand reporters
spécialisé relation internationales et
Mathieu croissant auditoris politique
bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à vous que
sait-on Christine Dubois Clément je
commence avec vous de cette
côte-offensive de l'Ukraine qui se
prépare en ce moment alors plusieurs
choses il y a eu déjà pas une seule mais
plusieurs petites contre-offensives ont
commencé à essayer de regagner de
regagner du terrain et ce qui est sûr
c'est que il y a un intérêt majeur à
essayer de limiter la sédentarisation
que l'on a eu alors votre reportage en
parler c'est-à-dire que pendant toute la
période
excusez moi où on a eu une phase de
guerre beaucoup plus d'usure avec
beaucoup moins de mouvements il y a eu
alors certes des petites avancées
particulièrement coûteuses côté russe
mais vous avez eu aussi une
russification une sédentarisation des
forces et une fortification de certaines
zones dans les territoires occupés par
la Russie avec la mise en place de
formation type base logistique notamment
dans les régions de Mario Paul et
meltilpol qui qui sont beaucoup plus
utilisés pour faire du stockage et de la
maintenance donc il y a réellement cet
intérêt à vouloir réavancer c'est une
des raisons qui fait qu'on a des
demandes massives notamment pour les
chars qui ont été évoqués et pour avoir
d'autres matériels donc par exemple des
avions pour pouvoir repousser et gagner
une supériorité moyenne générale
trinquant quels sont les conditions à
remplir quelque sorte les caches les
cases à cocher avant de se lancer dans
une contre-ensive comme celle-là je
pense qu'il faut bien distinguer deux
choses les contre-attaques qui ont eu
lieu là c'est à dire c'est des
opérations russes sur lesquelles on
monte des petites contre-attaques c'est
tactique un certain moment tactique pour
casser par exemple la fermeture des
pinces vous savez autour de bangkout et
la contre-offensive dont on parle qui
est un peu du même ordre que ce qui
s'est fait à Carson ou à carquif
le quatrième critère c'est la formation
des états majors on a parlé il y a
quelques semaines des worgames vous
savez avant ça s'appelait le cric fil en
allemand maintenant en anglais ça
s'appelle le hogame c'est la préparation
la simulation de l'offensive par les
états majors donc des avantages major
Ukrainiens qui sont allés s'entraîner
avec un état-major américain et qui leur
permet de simuler ça et puis le dernier
point on l'a cité tout à l'heure c'est
la raspoutizza c'est à dire que la boue
la boue que parce que la boue les
blindés y arrivent à peu près mais le
problème c'est que la logistique elle
est sur roues et donc elle elle pourra
pas progresser et donc on a besoin de
ces cinq éléments pour que ça fonctionne
bien et ma perception des choses ensuite
on parlera du terrain bien sûr et il y a
quelque chose qui est continue là-dedans
c'est le renseignement capter le
renseignement en permanence on a parlé
de la semaine dernière d'un drone
américain qui avait été abattu enfin qui
avait été poussé gentiment vers la mer
ça fait partie du renseignement qui est
fourni pour permettre d'alimenter les
dossiers et donc tous ces critères me
disent que l'offensive normalement elle
est pas pour tout de suite d'accord elle
est pour dans deux mois à peu près et il
y a une dimension qui est dans votre
démonstration parce que c'est l'effet de
surprise c'est-à-dire que là on est déjà
en train d'en parler pour qu'elle soit
efficace cette cette contre-offensive va
sans doute falloir des leurres enfin je
ne sais pas mais il va falloir créer
l'effet de surprise alors justement
aujourd'hui tout le monde regarde dans
la direction des aporidiens avec Meli
Paul en ligne de mire qui serait tout le
monde il y aura une contre-offensive ici
il y a 75000 hommes qui se massent ça
peut être à l'heure souvenez-vous au
moment de Kerson on pensait que tout que
l'armée ukrainienne allait attaquer car
sonne pas du tout en fait elle s'est
déployée complètement au nord il y a eu
l'offensive vers carquif avec izum etc
donc il y a bien des capacités aussi
pour les armées de nous envoyer des
leurs et de nous faire
envisager des d'une contre-offensive
alors quand on parle de la
contre-offensive de
[Musique]
utilisation il y a eu il y a de ça à peu
près trois semaines un mois toute cette
campagne autour de ce militaire
ukrainien qui avait dit face aux Russes
et qui était tué pratiquement et filmé
en train d'être abattu par l'armée russe
qui ne se battrait pour l'Ukraine
jusqu'au bout et donc on en a fait un
héros donc il y a une aussi
parallèlement et je crois que c'est très
important alors où les Ukrainiens sont
en train de reconstituer des brigades
parce qu'ils ont aussi besoin d'hommes à
l'heure où ils sont ils ont besoin
d'hommes et ils reconstituent des des
brigades et des unités ils ont besoin de
cette remobilisation de volontaire en
quelque sorte de peuple de population
donc il y a remobilisation de la
population remobilisation de l'armée
autour d'un projet la contrepensive et
l'emporter
à l'heure des satellites est-ce que en
effet de surprise est vraiment possible
bah écoutez c'était très bien expliqué à
propos de Carson Carson les Ukrainiens
ont joué à la fois
la fosse attaque mais qui était une
vraie attaque mais avec un décalage dans
le temps c'est à dire que tout le monde
l'attendait à Carson effectivement ils
étaient présents enfin dans la région de
Kerson ils étaient présents mais ils
progressaient pas beaucoup et d'un seul
coup attaque à Cartier et quand CARIF
c'est passé on attaque à Kerson donc
c'est ce type de manœuvre qui peut être
qui peut être joué parce que les
satellites bien sûr mais les troupes se
déplacer en tant qu'elles j'imagine je
vous donne un exemple l'échard qui
arrive aujourd'hui évidemment on dit pas
où ils sont et le problème ça va être si
c'est dans deux mois d'arriver avec des
munitions des chars des blindés etc et
d'arriver à ce que ça ne se voit pas
donc on n'a jamais détruit auparavant
par des frapperies exactement donc on a
déjà parlé des manœuvres de déception
des chars en plastique ou en etc donc il
y a effectivement une manœuvre de
déception très importante très
anglo-saxons sont assez bons dans les
manœuvres de déception donc les
Ukrainiens ont été bien formés à ça donc
je pense qu'il y a tous ces éléments là
effectivement et aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas juste un point sur meuble qui est un
point très intéressant parce que moi
j'avoue que
entre les apparidja et la mère d'Azov
elle a Crimée et oui un peu enfin au
coin de la merde
connaissent par cœur la carte de
l'Ukraine mais quand même
important c'est que c'est une zone qui
est marqué sur les cartes qu'on a comme
une zone d'instabilité pour l'armée
russe où il y a des partisans et là la
jonction entre l'armée ukrainienne et
des partisans pourraient être quelque
chose de très intéressant en fait vous y
prendre la parole peut-être sur
justement des informations comme comment
la guerre d'aujourd'hui comment on mène
ça plusieurs choses on parle beaucoup de
transparence tactique maintenant
justement avec la capacité que l'on a de
voir quasiment en temps réel avec les
systèmes satellitaires donc là je vous
rejoins c'est que tout ce qu'on va
appeler la déception ou l'intoxication
prend une part extrêmement importante
mais ça modifie aussi la façon dont on
fait la guerre c'est-à-dire ce que vous
disiez c'est à dire une mobilité
beaucoup plus rapide pour pouvoir
finalement vu qu'on va voir ce que vous
faites dans une certaine mesure même si
vous pouvez cacher il y a toujours la
dernière étape où bah vous êtes obligé
de sortir plus à découvert c'est à dire
d'être beaucoup plus sur de la
réactivité et de la capacité de
mouvement efficace et très fluide et ça
c'est quelque chose qui a été mis en
place par l'Ukraine depuis le début qui
ont une organisation qui est extrêmement
décentralisée qui est très agile donc
c'est vraiment d'aller sur ce travail là
et ça a été évoqué d'ailleurs par le
chef d'état-major de l'armée cette
transparence tactique qui était une des
grosses modifications et c'est là où on
va avoir beaucoup d'enjeux alors
évidemment vous le dit meilleur Zelenski
continue inlassablement de réclamer des
armes alors je vous propose un extrait
d'un discours qu'il avait fait en
visioconférence il était dans un train
et il le fait au moment où les
dirigeants européens se réunissent en
sommet à Bruxelles donc c'est jeudi
dernier et il a l'air dans ce dans cet
extrait qu'on a choisi sur les retards
de livraison
alors que chaque heure sur le champ de
bataille compte le retard dans le
transfert de missile à longue portée à
l'Ukraine et déjà important
cela ne nous permet pas de faire reculer
les positions des terroristes russes en
particulier de Kerson de zapporisja et
nos autres villes qui sont constamment
bombardées par des missiles russes à
longues portées 2050 dans ce même cette
même intervention il réclamait aussi le
président Zelenski des avions de combat
qui est prêt à lui en livrer qui a déjà
de donner son Go je crois qu'à la
Pologne alors la Slovaquie et la
Slovaquie parce que ce sont des mecs 29
et que les mines 29 sont les avions qui
s'est qui ont été en dotation pardon
dans la dans l'armée de les ukrainienne
donc ils savent les piloter voilà ils
savent les piloter alors ils ont été
modernisés mais l'adaptation est pas
très compliqué en revanche quand on
parle d'autres avions je parle des F-16
en particulier et des mirages 2000 par
exemple puisqu'on en a parlé c'est plus
long acclimater et puis il faut bien
voir que le réservoir de pilote
ukrainien n'est pas extensible ils ont
perdu des avions ils ont perdu des
malheureusement des pilotes aussi et ils
en avaient 50 à 60 et donc s'il faut
reprendre la formation du pilote depuis
que j'allais dire le toutano vous voyez
l'avion à hélice qui est la première
base pour apprendre comme ça et puis
après ça passait à l'Alphajet pour
parler français et puis après ça au
mirage mais ça prend une année en gros
donc c'est pas tout de suite en revanche
ce que le président zeninski souligne à
juste titre c'est le problème des
missiles à longue portée pourquoi parce
que la base de l'opération au nord c'est
la Biélorussie mais la base de
l'opération au sud c'est la Crimée et
pour taper sur il y a trois aéroports je
crois il y a des stocks de munitions etc
il y a besoin de tir à longue portée
alors ponctuellement ils l'ont fait avec
des drones mais ça n'est que ponctuel et
s'ils veulent monter une offensive
importante il faut quand même temps il
frappe dans la profondeur et pour
frapper dans la profondeur il faut qu'il
dispose des Rima qui tirent à 350 km
qui n'ont pas ceux qui tire à 180 km ça
veut dire pour l'instant il y a il y a
pas du tout de missile à longue portée
disponible pour la même ukrainienne ou
alors pas beaucoup c'est ils ont reçu
pour l'instant que des highmar qui
tirent à 150 km ils les ont reçu ceci
les Russes en ont parlé et apparemment
dans une gare
qui se trouve dans la zone donc près de
millipoles dans la zone effectivement
occupée par les par les Russes et bien
une gare a été touchée et de très
nombreuses locomotives et de train ont
été frappés et seul un missile tiré par
un de ces missiles GB je ne sais plus
tiré par un IMAP peut taper ici à 120 km
donc ils auraient bien pris en dotation
mais on voit aussi ce que le président
russe
ukrainien réclame c'est non seulement
des avions mais je crois surtout très
attaché aux défenses antimissiles aux
défenses patriotes ils réclament des
missiles patriotes de plus en plus il va
en avoir certains mais ça ne suffira pas
assurer assurer sa défense
techniquement ça serait d'essayer
d'arriver à faire ce que jusque là la
Russie n'arrive pas à mettre en œuvre ou
pas dans les mesures qui auraient été
voulu par le Kremlin c'est à dire
changer les réalités de terrain par une
action militaire suffisamment forte pour
essayer de limiter le cercle des
possibles et amener ou essayer de
ramener à la raison là aussi pour
arriver sur une phase de négociation
donc il faut une victoire militaire il
en faudrait même plusieurs suffisamment
éclatantes en quelque sorte pour ouvrir
alors j'aurais tendance à vous dire que
c'est probablement une condition
nécessaire mais pas forcément suffisante
puisqu'on est sur une une stratégie
assez jusqu'au-boutiste de la Russie
mais on a néanmoins besoin de cela
puisque à l'heure actuelle quand vous
regardez les propositions est-ce qu'ils
disent qu'il veut bien aller à la table
des négociations ça s'appelle pas de la
négociation mais de la capitulation ce
qu'il propose donc on a vraiment besoin
d'avoir cet ensemble là si vous voulez
pour essayer d'arriver à pousser vers
vers une sortie du conflit qui ne soit
pas une torsion du bras assez violente
de l'Ukraine alors on l'a compris
avant cette contre-offensive dans les
dans les semaines dans les mois qui
viennent il y a la question évidemment
des des armes que nous sommes
occidentaux en capacité à livrer je
propose à Jonathan du prix de nous
rejoindre bonsoir Jonathan bienvenue sur
le plateau de sciences publiques
intensification du soutien militaire et
donc une livraison délivraisons accrue
en armement oui tout à fait c'est le
ministre des Armées lui-même qu'il a
annoncé dans les colonnes du Figaro il y
a deux jours vous allez le voir pour
aider à cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne la France elle va doubler la
livraison d'obus de 155 mm pour la
porter à 2000 par mois à partir de la
fin mars donc c'est maintenant c'est ce
qu'il a dit au journal ses obus
d'artillerie l'Ukraine et bien l'entire
des quantités industrielles chaque jour
Thomas et ce modèle que la France donc
va livrer spécifiquement convient aux
annonces César la France elle en a livré
elle va en tout cas en livrer 30 au
total à l'Ukraine et c'est une arme
assez prisée des combattants Ukrainiens
qui est très mobile précise et qui porte
jusqu'à 40 à 50 km ce qui permet de
tirer derrière les
dans laquelle je le crois nous allons
durablement de voir nous organiser
c'est-à-dire aussi une économie dans
laquelle il faudra aller plus vite
réfléchir différemment sur les rythmes
les montées en charge les marges
voilà et il a martelé aussi un message
hier à l'Elysée ces industrielle doivent
prendre des risques accrus rompre avec
des programmes d'armement trop
sophistiqués et aller beaucoup plus vite
pour répondre aux commandes à la fois à
l'export et sans négliger l'équipement
de nos propres forces alors ce discours
au sein de défense c'était donc au mois
de juin qu'est-ce qu'il y a évolué
qu'est-ce qui a changé depuis alors sur
certaines armes dont on a beaucoup parlé
dont je viens de vous parler encore les
cadences sont fortement améliorées sous
la pression des commandes toujours plus
nombreuses nexters aujourd'hui peut
produire environ 6 canons César par mois
contre 2 avant la guerre en Ukraine mais
ces armes elles restent des produits de
haute technologie pour monter en cadence
il faut investir beaucoup en fait pour
ces entreprises et ce qui implique
d'avoir un carnet de commandes bien
fourni comme le soulignait le sénateur
LR Cédric Perrin qui a un spécialiste
des questions d'armement écoutez-le vous
n'avez pas demandé un chef d'entreprise
de faire des de faire des d'investir
massivement pour augmenter sa cadence et
d'augmenter ses moyens de production
aussi derrière il n'a pas des commandes
donc le coeur de la problématique il est
financier il est quels seront les moyens
qui seront mis dans la loi de
programmation militaire pour faire en
sorte que des commandes arrivent et que
les industriels puissent en tout cas
amortir leur coût de production et
accélérer les les productions de
certains matériels après il est bien
évident qu'il y a des matériels pour
lesquels c'est très compliqué parce que
si on prend l'exemple des obus de 155 la
problématique aujourd'hui c'est pas
forcément l'obur lui-même c'est la les
poudres propulsives qui posent des
difficultés qu'on n'a pas etc et pour
renforcer notre souveraineté en matière
d'armement le ministère des armées
envisage de relocaliser une vingtaine de
de points stratégiquement stratégique
c'est on peut dire voilà produire
notamment pourquoi pas des pièces
d'hélicoptères ou encore des explosifs
gros calibres dans l'Hexagone chez nous
merci et Jonathan général trinquant
est-ce qu'on a basculé en économie de
guerre
alors
basculer en économie guerre ça veut pas
dire que ça démarre tout de suite ça
veut dire qu'il faut lancer alors on
parlait de la relocalisation il y a des
décisions qui ont été prises
qui ont été prises sur l'accélération en
particulier dans les obus et dans les
canons de César qui est une accélération
de la production maintenant on parle
beaucoup des commandes on a on a un
problème c'est que pas mal d'armements
qui sont faits dans les entreprises
françaises pour l'armée française ne
sont quasiment pas exportables le
système scorpion par exemple on a fait
un accord avec la Belgique ça marche
bien avec la Belgique mais le système
scorpion déjà c'est le système des
blindés globalement je vais pas décrire
tous les blindés mais griffons etc
Jaguar etc et avec un système une boucle
fermée informatique qui permet d'avoir
beaucoup de sécurité et donc et puis
beaucoup de rapidité mais à l'intérieur
de cette boucle et ça on a monté un
programme avec les Belges qui ont pris
la même chose donc très bien mais on a
beaucoup de mal à le vendre ailleurs
parce que les spécifications françaises
sont pas forcément les spécifications
des autres pays donc il y a un décalage
qui existe si vous voulez entre l'export
ou notre ex dans les entreprises on n'a
pas parlé d'assaut parce que les les
rafales en revanche fonctionnent bien à
l'export depuis que le Rafale a été en
opération mais pour les matériels
terrestres on a des problèmes le césar
est un beau succès bravo le reste le
char on en a plus à mettre alors on
parlait de la capacité de fournir ces
armements généralement qu'est-ce qu'on
fournit on fournit des armements à part
le César on fournit des armements qui
vont quitter l'armée française la mise
du CRC par exemple est remplacée par le
jaguar donc on peut le céder parce que
ça va pas pénaliser très longtemps
l'armée française mais pour les autres
équipements c'est un problème Christine
ou un Clément quand le chef d'État parle
de risque du fait que le les industries
d'argent doivent prendre des risques ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que lancer
des de la production sont forcément
avoir des commandes publiques c'est
c'est quoi la logique il y a beaucoup de
choses là-dedans donc on voit bien qu'on
est dans un conflit qui qui va se mettre
dans le temps alors en parallèle en
printemps dernier la Russie elle avait
lancé par texte de loi par ukaz une
économie qui pour le coup ça part en
très clairement une économie de guerre
c'est-à-dire que c'est à dire qu'ils
veulent relancer la production vous êtes
capable de rappeler les gens sur leurs
congés que vous êtes capable de passer
entre 8 que vous êtes capable de passer
au-delà des marchés publics et que vous
êtes capable d'aller récupérer le
matériel et les capacités du secteur
privé pour les besoins du secteur public
par exemple
quant à savoir s'ils ont réussi à avoir
une production avec qui est fait une
augmentation exponentielle c'est
difficile à dire puisque comme on le
disait on a un jeu d'information entre
ce que l'on dit ce que l'on dit pas
évidemment quand on y arrivera à pas le
mettre en avant je disais l'annuaire
Poutine tout à l'heure dans dans
l'extrait qu'on a écouté ou il met en
parallèle les chars qu'il est en
capacité de produire face à ceux annoncé
par par les occidentaux on a on a tout
tout un principe déclaratoire là dedans
et une rhétorique qui est mise en place
et qui nécessite d'avoir des
vérifications multiples avant d'y
accorder un crédit trop important pour
dire cela de manière pudique cela dit
quand on parle de prise de risque c'est
aussi simple parce que vous le disiez
très justement elle sénateur le disait
c'est à dire que un industriel il a
besoin d'avoir et ben du cash flow il a
besoin d'avoir un fond de roulement donc
il a besoin d'avoir des commandes en
fixe et de pouvoir le faire là ce que il
y a eu des déclarations au niveau de
l'Union européenne qui incitait les
États membres à éventuellement puiser
dans leur stock pour pouvoir assurer les
fournitures qui sont demandées par
l'Ukraine et on risque d'avoir peut-être
un moyen terme un problème dans la
capacité à fournir on parlait des pros
des poudres propulsives et de la poudre
noire notamment et bien par exemple ça
on l'a fait venir pour partie
d'Australie parce qu'on n'est pas en
capacité de le faire donc on risque de
voir peut-être même aller à l'extérieur
pour acheter du matériel que l'on
Fournial juste parce que vous parliez de
l'effort de production russe je me
souviens qu'il y a six mois on disait
les sanctions tel effet que les Russes
ont plus de puces électronique ils sont
obligés démonter celles qui sont dans
les frigos pour
c'est vrai c'est faux
[Musique]
à détourner à détourner et puis il y a
tout un système de détournement qui
s'est fait par le Kazakhstan
l'Ouzbékistan etc et donc il suffit
d'acheter des puces parfois toutes bêtes
ou de commander des réfrigérateurs pour
pour se fournir et puis il y a eu les
fournisseurs donnés par la Chine malgré
tout on en parle peu et par la Corée en
volume les Russes le président en
Poutine a lancé qu'ils allaient produire
1300 chars l'année prochaine donc en
volume ils peuvent peut-être y arriver
en qualité c'est un autre sujet les
chats les derniers chars les derniers
modèles de char russe par exemple
avaient des conduites de tir et des
caméras de vision nocturne fournies par
Thalès qui évidemment ne sont plus
fournis et donc ils ne savent pas les
fabriquer de la même façon ça veut pas
dire qu'ils feront pas quelque chose
mais ils feront pas quelque chose de la
même qualité voilà ce que ça veut dire
ça aussi cette guerre a passé à la
manière enfin ça rejoint ce que disait
Jonathan sur le on va dire le l'économie
de guerre ou l'effort de guerre de de
nos industries la France elle avait un
modèle de d'intervention qui quoi qui
est totalement dépassé aujourd'hui il
faut il faut il faut le modifier il faut
se préparer un conflit à haute intensité
le modèle d'intervention choisit
effectivement par la France c'était une
armée réduite avec des projections à
l'extérieur et de quelques dizaines de
milliers d'hommes mais regardez Serval
c'était 5000 hommes quoi enfin je veux
dire bon voilà donc c'est c'est ça rien
à voir là effectivement le président se
retourne vers une guerre
dit-il de haute intensité comme tous les
pays européens alors avec avec quand
même je trouve quelque chose de logique
dans cette guerre on a l'Europe au
milieu mais on a d'un côté la Russie qui
elle se prépare vous à une guerre à mon
avis longue il Vladimir Poutine a le
temps pour lui il il a le temps même si
on dit que les sanctions commencent à
marcher et à faire leur petit effet
certains pensent aussi que c'est
beaucoup pour faire plaisir à son ami
chinois qui a besoin que la Russie
produise plus on va pas rentrer dans
tous ces détails mais on a quand même
Vladimir Poutine qui marche sur un temps
on va dire peut-être pas très long mais
il peut se faire deux trois ans et on a
face à lui les États-Unis qui eux
marchent sur un tout autre temps il y a
les élections américaines qui se
profilent qui vont arriver l'année
prochaine et là les Américains sont dans
une autre logique rappelez-vous que
enfin il y a quelques jours ce week-end
Donald Trump a tout simplement dit très
simplement moi si je vois Vladimir
Poutine en 48 heures l'affaire elle est
réglée alors c'est du bluff peut-être
mais ça on dit non sur ce qu'il pense de
l'Ukraine est-ce que les autres
candidats républicains sont dans le même
état d'esprit le gouverneur de Floride
qui est son rival potentiel mais qui à
mon avis ne sortira peut-être pas du
bois pense la même chose peut-être avec
le plus doux le flot de l'armement
américain pourrait se tarir en cas d'une
victoire République
sera essentiellement tourné vers la
Chine et donc
on y reviendrait
mais c'est intéressant je vous donnerai
la parole là-dessus mais on va boucler
ce chapitre qu'on consacré finalement à
la France Mathieu puisque la guerre en
Ukraine elle continue de diviser la
classe politique française petite touche
mais qui traduise une forme d'embarras
quand même un tenu hier par exemple
l'Assemblée nationale a reconnu comme
génocide lolodo mort vous savez cette
famine provoquée par l'Union soviétique
en Ukraine au début des années 30 et qui
a provoqué son résistoriens entre deux
et cinq millions de morts c'est aussi
une décision historique à saluer le
président ukrainien volo du meilleur
zazenski peu après le vote du texte il y
a une décision évidemment très
symbolique le texte il était rédigé par
la député Renaissance angienta il avait
été consigné par des membres de 7
groupes parlementaires sur 10 il a été
adopté à la quasi unanimité son 168 voix
contre deux mais sans la France
insoumise qui n'a pas pris part au vote
des députés et les filles ont mis des
doutes sur le caractère génocidaire au
regard du droit international nul ne
peut nier la réalité du crime mais
d'exterminer le peuple ukrainien en tant
que tel à financer le député LFI Bastien
Lachaud alors qu'est-ce que ça traduit
une gêne un minima mais elle est fille
j'ai une forme de tradition un défi
avait fait la même chose à propos du
génocide des Ouigours de la part de la
Chine ils avaient refusé de voter une
résolution de l'Assemblée nationale mais
ça montre quand même un peu plus d'un an
après le déclenchement de la guerre il
les insoumis sont toujours gênés aux
entournures dès qu'il s'agit de
s'écarter alors de la ligne prorus
affiché autrefois par Jean-Luc Mélenchon
devenu surtout une ligne antioxydale
anti-autant et parfois anti-Europe alors
tous reconnaissent aujourd'hui la
responsabilité de la Russie dans le
conflit mais il continue à se distinguer
du reste de la classe politique je vous
donne deux exemples le 30 novembre
dernier au Palais Bourbon ils ont ainsi
refusé de voter une résolution apportant
le soutien de plus total de l'Assemblée
nationale à l'Ukraine à son peuple à sa
souveraineté à son intégrité
territoriale et qui condamnait le crime
d'agression russe pourquoi parce qu'il
est jugé si je résume
contre-productif pour la réussite de
futures négociations et huit jours plus
tôt au Parlement européen cette fois-ci
il la tenue de voter un texte qualifiant
la Russie de d'État promoteur du
terroriste c'est un texte qui avait été
proposé par des députés européens en
s'appuyant sur les exécutions du groupe
Wagner alors là on parle des insoumis
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire du
rassemblement national le rassemblement
national à lui aussi bien du mal à
purger son passé pro russe les députés
Rennes se sont abstenus comme les
insoumis à l'assemblées nationales fin
novembre pas sur le moment et au
Parlement européen ils avaient carrément
voté contre justement le président du
Rassemblement national Jordan Bardella a
tenté de changer la donne oui c'était le
23 février dernier il a déclaré dans le
journal d'opinion qu'il y avait eu une
naïveté collective à l'égard des
ambitions et des intentions Vladimir
Poutine et il avait appelé au retrait
des troupes russes au retour elle
souveraineté pleine et entière de
l'Ukraine une petite phrase qui est pas
passée inaperçue et qui lui a surtout
valu d'être démenti deux jours plus tard
par Marine Le Pen
œuvré à la paix n'est pas un acte
d'allégeance à corriger l'ex-candidate à
la présidentielle sans rien cacher de
ces divergence avec Jordan Marley là
l'heure du Muya culpa n'a donc toujours
pas sonné merci Mathieu voilà pour ce
chapitre français dans notre débat très
con revienne maintenant peut-être à la
aux forces russes Dominique trinquant et
je commence avec vous on a je pense la
dernière fois qu'on a fait un débat sur
l'Ukraine ici il y a eu beaucoup de
débats évidemment et d'émissions
spéciales consacrées à la réforme des
retraites et c'était logique on était
tous centrés autour de bac mood la ville
devrait tomber la ville est encerclée
finalement elle est pas tombée cette
ville donc il y a non mais c'est
important de le dire
oui oui c'est une question de jour vous
avez raison et et donc le symbole est
important alors le symbole tout le monde
pense au symbole moi je pense qu'il y a
un effet tactique aussi très important
la tradition des forces russes on dit
alors les chiffres sont contestables que
les Russes perdent 7 combattants pour un
combattant ukrainien donc quand vous
calculez depuis le temps que ça dure ils
ont perdu quand même beaucoup de
combattants on le voit bien d'ailleurs
pour Wagner qui commence à se retirer de
la faire parce qu'il s'aperçoivent qu'il
n'arrive pas à déboucher ils vont passer
le relais à l'armée russe qui a pas
l'air de trop déboucher donc
deuxième point abcès de fixation quand
vous créez un accès de fixation comme ça
tout le monde en fait tout le monde
pardon les Russes concentrent leur force
là ainsi une trompe pas l'aviation russe
était absente du ciel ukrainien
l'aviation russe est revenue dans le
ciel de batmouth ça veut dire que c'est
vraiment un effort pour eux donc ils ont
mis ils ont perdu beaucoup de monde et
ils se sont concentrés là-dessus et du
coup les Ukrainiens c'est pas seulement
symbolique le président zeninski est
allé à backmouth probablement pour
soutenir le moral des soldats le chef
d'état-major y était allé la semaine
précédente donc c'est pour dire tenez et
on en revient toujours à la
contre-offensive parce qu'on va préparer
une offensive ailleurs donc tenez-la que
les Russes se concentrent là vous les
épuisez là et nous on attaquera ailleurs
et sur la chronologie je voudrais juste
un peu revenir sur ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure à propos de l'élection
américaine c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle il faut réussir quelque chose
avant la fin de l'année 2023 parce que
on n'est pas pas du tout du soutien que
donneront les Américains en 2024 vous
dites
la contre-offensive c'est une arme à un
coût c'est ça moi je dis c'est un fusil
à coup un fusil à un coup à loupé quoi
non mais il faut pas louper parce que
ils ont pas des réserves fantastiques
les ukrainiens et donc il faut on leur
donne le matériel les munitions les
personnels entraîner etc il faut qu'il
réussisse ce coup-là pour basculer
effectivement le rapport de force et que
les Russes alors après moi je c'est pas
lire après si c'est ce qui se passera en
Russie mais que ça déstabilise tellement
la Russie qu'on se pose des questions
le risque le risque c'est de voir se
reformer et pour un certain temps un
front comme on avait le fronde depuis
2015 autour de Donetsk avec et bien
c'est moi avec une trentaine de morts
parce que la guerre n'a jamais cessé
depuis 2015 et en fait depuis 2015 ça
n'a pas beaucoup bougé à part vers
mille-paul Mario Paul et le Sud mais le
front sinon risque de se former donc
pour eux c'est vital d'enfoncer et pour
enfoncer il faut des chars on leur en a
promis une centaine ils ont réclament
plus parce que vraiment pour faire une
percée c'est et je parle sous votre
autorité c'est il faut un peu plus de un
peu plus de 50 tiers alors vous on
continue par les bacs vous parliez des
milices Wagner j'aurais bien vous vous
entendre là-dessus Christine ou un
Clément parce que moi j'étais surpris en
préparant l'émission il y a eu de très
lourdes pertes aussi pour les milices
Wagner Wagner ils ont plusieurs
problèmes ils ont déjà essuyé des pertes
qui étaient extrêmement importantes
alors on parle beaucoup de barthout mais
on devrait parler de Solidar puisque on
avait fait beaucoup de bruit sur la
prise de cette ville parce que justement
en arrivait pas à prendre darkmouth à ce
moment là donc il y a une ville qui
était au milieu de sa forme à peu près à
15000 habitants quand on est à un petit
peu moins de 80 000 pareil au mieux de
sa forme et à l'origine sur barmouth qui
est très loin d'être le cas aujourd'hui
bien évidemment mais si vous voulez il y
a déjà eu énormément de pertes et le des
problèmes d'arriver à coordonner et les
forces russes de l'armée et les
miliciens de Wagner et puis ils ont eu
d'autres soucis c'est qu'ils ont
beaucoup de contrats qui arrivent à
échéance c'est à dire que beaucoup de
mercenaires vont être libérés notamment
certains qui avaient été recrutés dans
les prisons pour des contrats de 6 mois
contre une grâce et apparemment on
arrive à voir en source ouverte que et
bien le contrat est rempli puisque
certains ont été graciés et libérés et
ils vont revenir dans la mesure que
voilà vous alors ça c'est le côté c'est
que d'un point de vue sociétal vous
risquez d'avoir des délinquants en règle
générale avec dépassés violents qui vont
se retrouver réinjectés dans la société
civile et potentiellement avec des
syndromes de choc post-traumatique non
négligeable donc ça ça risque de faire
un petit problème sociétal côté
Fédération de Russie mais le dans le
prolongement Wagner n'a plus les
autorisations que le groupe avait
précédemment pour aller recruter dans
les prisons donc ce qui limite le vivier
donc vous avez une limitation de Viviers
vous avez des gens qui partent et vous
avez en plus beaucoup de pertes donc
tout ça ça fait quand même une vraie une
véritable attrition et puis il y a au
trio d'autres choses côté armée russe
c'est que notamment ils avaient créé un
troisième corps d'armée qui était la
grosse formation farine des grosses
formations importantes qui avait été
créée par la Russie en pour soutenir
l'invasion à partir d'août de l'année
dernière qui était connu pour avoir des
gros problèmes de discipline des gros
problèmes de morale et dont par exemple
une unité qui est le dixième origine le
10e régiment de char a été fortement
détruit autour d'hadifica puisqu'il y a
un effort très important qui est mené à
l'heure actuelle autour de la qui est
devenu une zone rouge classée par
l'Ukraine c'est à dire qu'une
journaliste ni volontaire ne peuvent y
venir et le deuxième point c'est comment
est-ce qu'on va gérer finalement ce
problème de formation puisque ces hommes
là ont été probablement formés en
diélorussie et sont quand même de
qualité pour le moins médiocre tout en
sachant que vous avez une vague de
conscription qui va redémarrer au mois
d'avril puisque l'armée russe fonctionne
sur deux conscriptions une au printemps
et une à l'automne c'était la question
que j'allais vous poser une nouvelle
mobilisation en général mais partir
en
conscriptions ne pourront pas être ça ne
pourront pas être utilisé avant quatre
mois donc si vous à partir de l'été un
mot sur Wagner on se rappeler que Wagner
c'est du business et le business il se
fait où en Libye en Centrafrique au Mali
là il gagne de l'argent
en
Ukraine il perd de l'argent et il était
il était capable de mettre de l'argent
sur la table pour essayer d'avoir une
place politique or comme il n'a pas
remporté de victoire et qui sait
brouillé avec une grande partie de
l'armée et bien il a pas obtenu cette
place politique et c'est pour ça qu'il
se pose des questions actuellement et
qu'il a fait une déclaration en disant
qu'il voulait se
concentré sur les zones africaines parce
que c'est là qu'il gagne de l'argent ça
peut aussi un peu du chantage
par rapport mais cette conscription et
toute cette cette déperdition qui a en
termes d'hommes ou de blessés on parle
de 200 000 voire plus de mort et de
blessés ça pose aussi un vrai problème
économique parce que c'est toutes les
toutes les populations qui étaient
plutôt de l'autre côté de l'Oural on
fait pas la conscription à Moscou à
Saint-Pétersbourg on évite on va dans
toutes ces régions mais c'est dans ces
régions là il y a beaucoup d'usines
chinoises et il y a manque de main
d'oeuvre et je peux vous dire que
c'était une un des sujets de
conversation
entre le premier enfin entre le premier
minis chinois et le président russe
Christine
pour avoir des volontaires qui
s'engagent dans l'armée russe pour
soutenir l'invasion et les chiffres que
l'on avait pu recroiser annoncer quelque
chose comme autour de 20000 personnes en
décembre par rapport à une mobilisation
partielle de 200000 ce qui est très
faible et il y a aussi des déclarations
qui expliquent qu'on a du mal à
mobiliser les jeunes or ce sont quand
même ceux qui sont les premiers à être
employés dans ce conflit alors il y a un
dernier thème dont je récompense et vous
volontairement j'y ai pas consacré
beaucoup de temps dans ce débat parce
que à chaque fois qu'on parle de
nucléaire vous nous dites il faut
arrêter de faire peur aux opinions
publiques au plus opinions publiques
occidentales oui vous pourriez me
prendre au mot mais quand même ça fait
partie des événements de ces derniers
jours l'annonce par le numéro Poutine du
déploiement d'armes nucléaire tactique
chez son voisin biélorus on écoute le
président russe
le président de Biélorussie soulève
depuis longtemps la question du
déploiement d'armes nucléaire tactique
russe sur son territoire
il n'y a rien d'inhabituel
les États-Unis agissent de la sorte de
puits il place depuis longtemps leurs
armes nucléaires tactiques sur le
territoire de leurs alliés les pays de
l'OTAN en Europe
vous allez nous dire que ça change pas
grand chose non la seule chose que ça
démontre c'est la vassalisation de la
Biélorussie elle est complètement à la
mode des États-Unis pardon de la Russie
qui qui décide de mettre de l'armement
là c'était un accord qui datait déjà un
an donc là c'est la concrétisation de
l'accord ça ne change pas grand chose le
président russe n'a pas tort en parlant
de l'armement américain qui est dans les
pays européens puisqu'il est en place
depuis très longtemps il s'agit en
particulier de l'Europe de l'Ouest n'a
pas de l'Europe de l'Ouest et donc donc
voilà moi je crois que c'est surtout la
position de la Biélorussie qui perd
toute crédibilité dans cette affaire
Christine loi Clément là-dessus
peut-être pour les pays
frontaliers de la Biélorussie qui sont
membres de l'OTAN ça change ça change
quelque chose dans les opinions
publiques de ces pays en fait on est
dans dans des choses qui sont un petit
peu classiques donc Yousef qu'un démon
du renseignement ukrainien parler d'un
instrument de chantage nucléaire à la
naphtaline pour donner un petit peu
l'image faut pas oublier que dans
l'esclave et pas l'enclave de
Kaliningrad vous avez déjà des
déploiements 10knders qui sont en fait
des missiles qui ont la capacité
d'emport de charge nucléaire or vous
êtes déjà au début et rappelons-le ce
déploiement a eu lieu en 2016 donc au
moment où on avait eu énormément de
pression notamment autour de autour de
la Crimée autour de l'application d'un
application des traités de mine ce
gamins que de donc ce sont des choses
que l'on voit ce qui est assez
intéressant c'est que finalement ça a
été assez peu repris notamment par tout
ce qu'on a sur la sphère des blogueurs
militaires russes et on voit bien que
c'est plus fait finalement pour les
occidentaux que pour que beaucoup plus
opinions publiques clairement que pour
de la politique que pour de la politique
intérieureuse donc cas particulier je
trouve plus intéressant en ce moment
c'est le la non communication de ce qui
se passe sur le terme en terme de
d'armes nucléaire et de entre les deux
pays entre les États-Unis et la Chine il
y a plus de communication les canaux de
communication sur les déploiement et les
tests d'armes nucléaire
et la Chine et la Russie et la Russie
qui était en théorie dans les accords
solt 2 et tout ça c'est rompu et donc ça
c'est plus inquiétant je trouve merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat c'était passionnant je vous
dis à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat